maligayang pagbabalik sa pag-unawa sa Quantum na impormasyon at komputasyon ang pangalan ko ay John Wattrus at ako ang teknikal
na direktor para sa edukasyon sa IBM Quantum ito ang ika-11 na aralin ng serye at ito ang ikatlong aralin sa
ikatlong yunit na tungkol sa pangkalahatang pormulasyon ng quantum na impormasyon ang araling ito ay tungkol sa mga sukat na kumakatawan sa isang
interface sa pagitan ng Quantum at classical na impormasyon kapag ang isang sukat ay ginagawa sa isang sistema habang ito ay nasa isang
Quantum State ang classical na impormasyon ay nakuha na nagbubunyag ng isang bagay tungkol sa Quantum State na iyon at sa pangkalahatan ay nagbabago o
nagwawasak ng estado na iyon sa proseso sa isang pinasimpleng pormulasyon ng quantum na impormasyon na tinalakay
sa unang yunit ng serye ay karaniwang inililimita natin ang ating pansin sa mga projective measurement kabilang ang
pinakasimpleng uri ng sukat na mga standard basis measurement gayunpaman ay posible na gawing pangkalahatan ang konsepto ng isang sukat
at lumalabas na isang medyo kapaki-pakinabang na bagay na gawin sa araling ito ay pag-uusapan natin ang tungkol sa mga sukat sa buong pangkalahatang
kabilang ang kung paano sila inilalarawan sa mathematical na mga termino at kung paano sila angkop sa pangkalahatang pormulasyon ng quantum
impormasyon sa bandang dulo ng aralin ay titingnan din natin ang ilang pundamental na mga konsepto na konektado sa mga sukat kabilang ang Quantum State
discrimination at Quantum State tomography kaya magsimula na tayo narito ang isang pangkalahatang-ideya ng
aralin tulad ng madalas nating ginagawa ay magsisimula tayo sa mga pangunahing kaalaman kabilang ang ilang iba't ibang ngunit katumbas na mga paraan na
maaari naming ilarawan ang mga sukat sa mathematical na mga termino sa partikular ay maaari nating ilarawan ang mga sukat gamit ang mga koleksyon ng matrix
at maaari rin nating ilarawan ang mga ito bilang mga channel na binanggit ko sa nakaraang aralin pag-uusapan din natin ang partial
na mga sukat o sa ibang salita ang mga sukat na ginagawa sa isang bahagi lamang ng isang mas malaking compound
sistema pagkatapos ay lilipat tayo sa teorema ni neymark na isang pundamental na katotohanan tungkol sa mga sukat na karaniwang
nagsasabing ang mga Pangkalahatang sukat ay palaging maaaring ipatupad sa isang simpleng paraan na nagpapaalala ng Stein spring
na mga representasyon ng mga channel sa madaling salita ang mga Pangkalahatang sukat ay palaging maaaring ipatupad sa pamamagitan ng unang pagpapakilala ng isang
na-initialize na workspace system pagkatapos ay gumaganap ng isang unitary operation at sa wakas ay gumaganap ng isang standard basis
measurement sa workpace system lumalabas na ito ay medyo madaling patunayan at makikita natin kung paano iyon nagaganap at
makikita rin natin kung paano ito kumokonekta sa tinatawag na mga non-destructive measurement na ilalarawan ko sa wakas sa huling bahagi ng
aralin ay tatalakayin natin ang Quantum State discrimination at Quantum State tomography magsisimula tayo sa mathematical
na mga paglalarawan ng mga sukat ang mga sukat ay nagbibigay sa atin ng interface sa pagitan ng Quantum at
classical na impormasyon kapag ang isang sukat ay ginagawa sa isang sistema habang ito ay nasa ilang Quantum State ang classical na impormasyon
tungkol sa Quantum state na iyon ay nakuha bukod dito ang quantum state ay sa pangkalahatan ay nagbabago o marahil ay
ganap na nawasak sa simula ay tutukan natin ang ating pansin sa tinatawag na mga destructive measurement kung saan
ang isang Quantum State ay pumapasok at ang classical na impormasyon lamang ang lumalabas kaya walang detalye ng
postmeasurement quantum state ng sistemang sinukat sa intuitibong pagsasalita maaari nating isipin na ang isang destructive measurement
ay nagwawasak ng anumang sistemang sinukat kaya ang estado nito pagkatapos ng sukat ay hindi
tinukoy hindi ito literal na nangangahulugan na ang mga pisikal na device ay kinakailangang nawasak ito ay isang mathematical lamang
na paglalarawan at ito ay isang napaka-kapaki-pakinabang na isa dahil tinutulungan nito na panatilihing simple ang mga bagay at makapag-focus sa mahahalagang
mathematical na aspeto ng mga sukat mayroon sa partikular na dalawang katumbas na paraan upang ilarawan ang mga destructive
measurement na binanggit ko sa panahon ng pangkalahatang-ideya ng aralin isang paraan upang ilarawan ang isang destructive
measurement ay sa pamamagitan ng isang koleksyon ng mga matrix kung saan sa partikular ay mayroon tayong isang Matrix para sa bawat posibleng resulta ng
sukat ang isa pang paraan upang ilarawan ang isang destructive measurement ay sa pamamagitan ng isang channel kung saan ang
input ay ang estado ng anumang sistema na sinusukat at ang output ay palaging isang diagonal density Matrix na maaari nating
bigyan ng interpretasyon bilang isang paglalarawan ng isang probability distribution sa mga posibleng classical na resulta ng
sukat ang dalawang paglalarawan ay katumbas at iyon ay medyo kapaki-pakinabang dahil nagpapahintulot ito sa atin na pumili kung aling paglalarawan ang mas maginhawa sa isang
ibinigay na sitwasyon pag-uusapan din natin ang tungkol sa mga non-destructive measurement kung saan bilang karagdagan sa isang classical na resulta ng
sukat ang postmeasurement Quantum state ng sistemang sinukat ay tinukoy din
ang mga non-destructive measurement ay mahalaga at madalas silang lumalabas ngunit mayroon isang kahulugan kung saan sila ay
medyo hindi gaanong pundamental kaysa sa mga destructive measurement sa mathematical na mga termino sa partikular lumalabas na
ang mga non-destructive measurement ay palaging maaaring ilarawan bilang mga komposisyon ng mga channel at mga destructive measurement at sa
makikita natin kung paano iyon gumagana nang kaunti mamaya sa aralin ngayon tingnan natin kung paano ang mga sukat ibig sabihin ang mga destructive
measurement ay maaaring ilarawan bilang mga koleksyon ng mga matrix sa buong talakayan na ito ay ipagpapalagay natin na ang X ay isang sistema na
sinusukat at para sa kapakanan ng Simplisidad ay gagawa tayo ng ilang pagpapalagay una ay ipagpapalagay natin na ang
classical State set ng X ay binubuo ng mga integer mula 0 hanggang n minus isa para sa ilang positibong integer n at ang mga posibleng
resulta ng sukat ay ang mga integer mula 0 hanggang M minus isa muli para sa ilang positibong integer M wala
namang kailangang anumang relasyon sa pagitan ng mga numero n at M sila ay parehong arbitrary na positibong integer at siyempre maaari nating palitan
ang mga set na ito ng mga arbitrary na classical State set kung gusto nating gawin iyon una ay alalahanin kung paano gumagana ang mga projective
measurement na pinag-usapan natin noong ikatlong aralin ng serye dahil ipinagpapalagay natin na ang mga resulta ng sukat ay mga integer mula 0 hanggang n minus isa ay inilalarawan natin ang isang projective measurement sa pamamagitan ng isang koleksyon
ng mga projection Pi 0 hanggang Pi M minus isa na nagkakabuuan sa identity Matrix at ang mga matrix na ito ay lahat may mga row at
column na naaayon sa mga classical state ng X o sa ibang salita ang mga ito ay lahat ng n byon
na mga matrix kung ang x ay nasa isang Quantum State na inilalarawan ng isang Quantum State Vector s kung gayon ang bawat posibleng resulta ng
sukat a ay lumalabas na may probabilidad na katumbas ng ukian norm squ ng Pi a na pinarami
sa vector s ang ukian norm squar ng anumang Vector ay katumbas ng inner product ng Vector
na iyon kasama ang sarili nito kaya nakukuha natin ang pagpapahayag na ipinapakita sa screen at maaari nating pasimplehin iyon nang kaunti
sa pamamagitan ng paggamit ng katotohanang ang Pi a ay isang projection kaya ang pagparami nito sa sarili nito ay hindi gumagawa ng
anumang bagay at sa wakas ay maaari nating isulat muli ang pagpapahayag na nakuha natin sa bahagyang iba pang paraan gamit ang cyclic property
ng trace muli tulad ng ipinapakita sa screen at kung hindi malinaw kung bakit natin gustong isulat ang pagpapahayag tulad nito ang
maikling sagot ay gusto nating maunawaan kung paano gumagana ang mga projective measurement para sa mga density
matrix at sa partikular sa pamamagitan ng linearidad mayroon tayong na kung ang estado ng X ay inilalarawan ng isang density Matrix row sa halip na
isang Quantum State Vector s kung gayon ang probabilidad para lumabas ang resulta a ay ibinibigay ng trace ng projection
Pi a oras ang density Matrix row kailangang ganoon ang kaso dahil tulad ng nakita natin
palagi nating maisip ang isang density Matrix bilang isang weighted average ng mga pure state at kung ina-average natin ang
kaukulang mga probabilidad ay makuha natin ang pagpapahayag na ito dahil ang trace ay isang linear function kaya iyon ang pagpapahayag na
hinahangad natin at maaari nating linisin ang mga bagay nang kaunti upang tumutok sa mga density
matrix ang pangunahing punto ng paggawa nito sa pamamagitan ng paraan ay ang magtatag ng isang punto ng sanggunian sa kung ano ang natutunan na natin
at upang makita na ang paglalarawang ito ng mga projective measurement ay talagang isang espesyal na kaso ng isang mas Pangkalahatang paglalarawan ng mga sukat na
malapit na nating makita kaya ang gagawin ko ngayon ay palitan ang paglalarawang ito ng kung paano gumagana ang mga projective measurement para sa mga density matrix
ng paglalarawan para sa mga Pangkalahatang sukat upang maunawaan natin ang relasyon at narito ito
ang isang pangkalahatang sukat na hindi kinakailangang isang projective measurement ay inilalarawan ng isang koleksyon ng mga positive semi-definite
matrix p 0 hanggang PM minus isa na nagkakabuuan sa identity at kung ang sukat na ito ay ginagawa sa X habang ito ay
nasa estado na inilalarawan ng isang density Matrix row kung gayon ang bawat resulta a ay lumalabas na may probabilidad na katumbas ng trace ng PA *
Row sa madaling salita ang tanging bagay na nagbago ay ang pinagaan natin ang kondisyon sa mga matrix na ito sa partikular ang mga matrix
ay hindi kailangang maging projection matrices kailangan lamang nilang maging positive semi-definite at naaayon dito ay pinalitan ko ang titik Pi ng titik p
dahil ang Pi ay isang conventional na pangalan para sa isang projection samantalang gusto ko ang titik P para sa positive semi-definite
matrix ito ay isang generalization ng paglalarawan na mayroon tayo para sa mga projective measurement sa pamamagitan ng paraan dahil ang mga projection matrix ay palaging positive
semi-definite at sa katunayan ay maaari silang alternatibong tukuyin bilang mga positive semi-definite matrix na ang mga eigen value
ay maaari lamang maging zero at isa maaari nating masundan na ang depinisyong ito
ay makatuwirang tinatanggap natin ang isang probability Vector para sa mga probabilidad ng resulta sa sumusunod
na paraan una ang mga numerong ito na tinutukoy ko bilang mga probabilidad ng resulta ay palaging mga non-negative na tunay na numero iyon ay
dahil ang parehong PA at row ay positive semi-definite at ang trace ng produkto ng dalawang positive semi-definite
matrix ay palaging isang non-negative na tunay na numero at iiwan ko iyon para sa inyong pag-iisip kung bakit iyon
ang kaso at pangalawa ang mga numero ay kailangang nagkakabuuan sa isa dahil ang trace ay linear ang
mga matrix p 0 hanggang PN minus 1 ay kinakailangang nagkakabuuan sa identity at ang mga density matrix ay may Trace na katumbas ng
isa kaya anuman ang density Matrix row na sinimulan natin ang mga probabilidad ng resulta ay palagi talagang bumubuo ng isang
probability Vector ngayon tingnan natin ang ilang halimbawa nabanggit ko na na
ang mga projective measurement ay isang espesyal na kaso ng mga Pangkalahatang sukat dahil ang mga projection ay palaging positive semi-definite
ngunit maganda na magsimula nang simple kaya magsimula tayo sa isang standard basis measurement ng isang cubit maaari nating katawanin ang isang standard basis
measurement ng isang cubit ng dalawang matrix p 0 at P1 na tinutukoy tulad ng ipinapakita sa screen ang p 0 ay z bra zero at ang P1 ay k1
bra isa ang mga ito ay parehong positive semi-definite matrix at talagang mga projection at malinaw silang nagkakabuuan sa
identity kaya magkasamang inilalarawan nila ang isang sukat kung ilalapat natin ang sukat na ito sa isang cubit
sa isang estado na inilalarawan ng isang density Matrix row kung gayon ang probabilidad para sa alcome zero na lumabas ay ang trace ng p 0 * row
at ang probabilidad para sa resulta na isa ay ang trace ng P1 * row at sa pamamagitan ng cyclic property ng trace ay nakuha natin
ang dalawang diagonal na entry ng row tulad ng inaasahan narito ang isa pang halimbawa kung saan ngayon
ang mga matrix ay hindi mga projection sila ay positive semidefinite ngunit nagkataon silang maging density
matrix ngunit hindi iyon mahalaga ngunit ang mahalaga ay nagkakabuuan sila sa identity kaya magkasama ay inilalarawan nila ang isang
sukat maaari nating makita kung ano ang nangyayari kapag ang sukat na ito ay ginawa sa isang cubit sa plus state halimbawa upang
makita kung paano gumagana para sa isang halimbawa ng isang estado at ang isang kalkulasyon ng mga probabilidad ay ipinapakita sa
screen pansinin sa partikular na bagaman ang plus state ay isang pure state at maaari nating katawanin ang estado na iyon ng quantum State Vector cat Plus ay kailangan pa rin nating
i-plug in ang density Matrix representation ng estado na iyon na siyang C plus BR plus sa mga formula upang makuha
ang mga probabilidad at banggitin ko rin na dahil kami ay nagtatalakay tungkol sa isang destructive measurement ay wala
namang detalye ng postmeasurement quantum state ng Cubit na ito kaya ang mayroon lamang tayo ay isang detalye ng mga probabilidad ng resulta
narito ang isang panghuling halimbawa para sa ngayon at ito ay isang medyo kawili-wiling isa muli ito ay isang sukat ng isang
solong Cubit at upang ilarawan ito ay magsisimula tayo sa pamamagitan ng pagtukoy ng apat na quantum State vector na kilala bilang mga tetrahedral
State at ang dahilan kung bakit sila tinatawag na mga tetrahedral State ay dahil naaayon sila sa apat na vertices ng
isang regular na tetrahedron na naka-inscribe sa loob ng block sphere at upang maging malinaw kapag sinasabi natin na ito ay isang regular na tetrahedron
ibig nating sabihin ay isang apat na panig na solido kung saan ang bawat isa sa mga mukha ay isang equilateral triangle kaya may perpektong simetriya dito bawat
Gilid ay may parehong haba at pareho ang anggulo na nabuo sa pagitan ng anumang dalawang magkatabing
gilid at ngayon ay maaari tayong mag-define ng isang kawili-wiling sukat na may apat na posibleng resulta tulad ng ipinapakita sa screen o sa mga salita ay maaari nating kunin ang ating
mga matrix bilang mga density Matrix representation ng mga estado na ito na hinati sa dalawa ngayon ang mga ito ay tiyak na positive
semi-definite matrix dahil ang mga density matrix ay hinati sa dalawa at maaari kang dumaan sa arithmetic upang suriin
na sila ay talagang nagkakabuuan sa identity ngunit ang isa pang paraan upang makita iyon ay ang mag-isip tungkol sa simetriya kung ina-average natin ang apat na estado na ito
ay makuha natin ang completely mixed state na nasa gitna ng block sphere ngunit dahil hinihati natin ang bawat isa sa dalawa kaysa sa apat ay makuha natin ang dalawang beses ng completely mixed state na siyang identity hindi ko sasabihin ang mas marami pa tungkol sa
sukat na ito para sa ngayon maliban sa mapansin na hindi ito isang projective measurement ngunit ito ay isang magandang halimbawa at
makikita natin itong lumabas muli mamaya sa aralin ang isa pang paraan upang ilarawan ang mga pangkalahatang sukat ay bilang mga channel tulad ng tatalakayin natin ngayon
ang ideya dito ay ang mga classical na probabilistikong estado ay maaaring katawanin ng mga diagonal density matrix at kaya
dahil ang mga resulta ng sukat ay classical ay maaari nating isipin ang tungkol sa mga sukat bilang mga channel kung saan ang output ay palaging isang diagonal density
Matrix na naglarawan ng resulta ng sukat kaya tingnan natin ito nang kaunti pa nang mas detalyado kung iniisip natin nang
abstract ang tungkol sa isang pangkalahatang sukat ay maaari nating ilarawan ang sukat na iyon bilang isang channel fi ang input system para sa channel ay
Matrix na naglarawan ng resulta ng sukat kaya tingnan natin ito nang kaunti pa nang mas detalyado kung iniisip natin ang
nang abstract tungkol sa isang pangkalahatang sukat ay maaari nating ilarawan ang sukat na iyon bilang isang channel fi ang input system para sa channel ay
anumang sistema X na sinusukat at ang output system ay isang sistema y na ang mga classical state ay naaayon sa
mga resulta ng sukat na inaakala nating mga integer mula 0 hanggang n minus isa para sa ilang positibong integer
M at dahil ang mga resulta ng sukat ay classical ay hinihiling natin na para sa bawat input density Matrix Row para sa sistema
X ang output five row ay dapat na isang diagonal density Matrix halimbawa kung iniisip natin ang isang
standard basis measurement ng isang cubit at iniisip natin ang sukat na iyon bilang inilalarawan ng isang channel maaari nating ipahayag ito tulad ng mayroon tayo dito sa screen
kung ang input density Matrix ay row makakakuha tayo ng resulta na zero na may probabilidad na katumbas ng bra 0o row cat Zer
at makakakuha tayo ng resulta na isa na may probabilidad na bra isa row Kat isa at kaya kung ipinahayag natin ang mga classical
na mga resulta ng sukat bilang mga density matrix ay makuha natin ang pagpapahayag na ito para sa kaukulang Channel at lumalabas na
wala itong iba kundi ang completely dephasing Channel at iyon ay pare-pareho sa ideya na ang completely dephasing
Channel ay kumakatawan sa isang matinding anyo ng decoherence na maaaring mangahulugan ng iba't ibang bagay ngunit kapag ginamit ko ang terminong iyon ay
pinag-uusapan ko ang tungkol sa tendensya ng Quantum States na maging classical dahil ang kapaligiran sa paligid ng anumang sistema na pinag-uusapan natin
ay nanonood sa ilang kahulugan o sa ibang salita ito ay sumusukat
kaya ang mga resulta ng sukat ay maaaring ilarawan bilang mga channel tulad ng inilarawan ko ngayon ngunit hindi lamang ito isang posibilidad ito ay isang
characterization ng mga Pangkalahatang sukat at ang ibig ko sabihin nito ay ang sumusunod siyempre may mga channel
na hindi kumakatawan sa mga sukat dahil ang output ay maaaring hindi palaging isang diagonal density Matrix ngunit kung ito ay
totoo na ang output ng isang channel ay palaging isang diagonal density Matrix anuman ang pumiling input State row ay ito ay kinakailangang posible na
ipahayag ang channel na iyon sa anyo na ipinapakita sa screen para sa ilang pagpili ng isang sukat ibig sabihin ang isang koleksyon ng
positive semidefinite matrix na nagkakabuuan sa identity at maganda iyon para sa maraming dahilan kabilang ang katotohanang
ito sa prinsipyo ay nagsasabi sa atin na ang ating depinisyon ng mga sukat bilang mga koleksyon ng matrix ay hindi nawawalan ng
anumang bagay ang isa pang paraan ng pagsabi nito ay ang paraan ng pag-iisip tungkol sa mga sukat bilang mga channel ay operational
o marahil axiomatic sa kahulugang nahuhuli nito kung ano dapat ang isang sukat na isang pisikal na proseso na
nag-transform ng Quantum na impormasyon sa classical na impormasyon at lumalabas na ito ay ganap na katumbas ng ating unang
paglalarawan ng mga sukat na puro algebraic hindi ko dadaanin ang patunay ng katumbasan sa video na ito ngunit ito
ay hindi mahirap at kung interesado ka ay maaari kang makahanap ng patunay sa nakasulat na materyal para sa aralin na naka-link sa video
description tinalakay na natin kung ano ang nangyayari kapag ang isang pangkalahatang sukat ay ginagawa sa isang sistema sa isang ibinigay na estado
kahit para sa kaso ng mga destructive measurement susunod ay pag-uusapan natin ang tungkol sa mga partial measurement ibig sabihin
ang isang bahagi lamang ng isang compound system ang sinusukat upang maging tiyak ipagpalagay nating mayroon tayong isang pares ng mga sistema XZ na
magkasamang nasa isang estado na inilalarawan ng isang density Matrix row at ang isang sukat na inilalarawan ng isang koleksyon ng positive semi-definite matrix na nagkakabuuan sa
identity ay ginagawa sa sistema X nag-iisa natural na nagreresulta ito sa isang
resulta ng sukat at dahil kami ay nagtatalakay tungkol sa mga destructive measurement ay maaari nating isipin na ang proseso ng pagsukat ay nagwawasak ng sistema
X ngunit mayroon pa rin tayong sistema Z na dapat alalahanin at kailangan nating maunawaan kung paano nakakaapekto ang pagsukat ng X sa
estado ng Z una ay pag-usapan natin ang tungkol sa mga probabilidad ng
resulta dahil kami ay nagtatalakay tungkol sa isang sukat ng sistema X nag-iisa ang mga probabilidad para sa iba't ibang
mga resulta na lumabas ay maaari lamang depende sa estado ng X nang mag-isa na ibig sabihin ay maaari lamang silang depende sa
reduced state ng X sa partikular ang probabilidad para sa isang ibinigay na resulta a na lumabas ay ibinibigay ng
parehong formula ng dati na siyang trace ng PA oras ng reduced state ng X na itinutukoy natin ng Row
subx ang estado row subx ay nakuha mula sa row sa pamamagitan ng pag-trace out ng Z kaya maaari tayong gumawa ng
pagpapalit na iyon at bagaman maaaring hindi agad na malinaw ang tanong na makuha natin ay maaaring alternatibong isulat tulad ng
ipinapakita sa screen ito ang trace ng PA tensored kasama ang identity Matrix sa sistema Z *
row ngayon iyon ay isang pagkakahalaga na tiyak na karapat-dapat sa oras na beripikahin ito ay intuitive hindi tayo gumagawa
ng anumang bagay sa Z kaya makatuwirang ang identity sa Z ay dapat lumabas tulad nito ngunit maaari rin itong ma-verify
algebraically at iiwan ko iyon sa inyo kasama ang mungkahi na una ay isaalang-alang ang kaso na ang row ay isang tensor product ng dalawang matrix at pagkatapos
ay gumamit ng linearidad upang mapatibay na dapat itong gumana para sa lahat ng row at sasabihin ko rin na hindi ito nakasalalay sa katotohanang ang PA
ay positive semi-definite o ang row ay isang density Matrix ito ay isang pagkakahalaga na gagana para sa anumang pagpili ng
mga matrix sa halip ng PA at row basta mayroon silang tamang mga dimensyon para sa pagpapahayag upang gumawa ng
kahulugan at ngayon tingnan natin kung paano ang estado ng Z ay naaapektuhan ng sukat at ang natural na diskarte sa
aking pagtingin ay ang isipin ang tungkol sa sukat bilang isang channel narito ang channel na iniuugnay natin sa ating sukat at iniisip natin
ang tungkol dito bilang isang channel mula sa sistema X patungo sa isang bagong sistema y na ang mga classical state ay naaayon sa mga resulta ng sukat kaya sa formula na ito
ang Sigma ay kumakatawan sa isang estado ng sistema X nag-iisa kung ilalapat natin ang channel na ito sa
sistema X habang ang pares XZ ay nasa estado row ay makuha natin ang density Matrix na mayroon tayo ngayon dito muli
ay maglaan ng oras kung kinakailangan upang beripikahin ito at muli ang aking mungkahi ay una ay isaalang-alang ang kaso na ang row ay isang tensor
product ng dalawang matrix at pagkatapos ay gumamit ng linearidad ngayon ay nakita natin ang uri ng estado
na ito kung saan ang unang sistema ay classical at ang pangalawang sistema ay quantum bilang isang halimbawa sa density Matrix
aralin ang bawat a ay lumalabas na may ilang probabilidad at iyon ang trace ng pangalawang tensor Factor kaya maaari mong isipin
ang tungkol sa mga pangalawang tensor factor na ito bilang mga density matrix na pinarami ng mga probabilidad kaya upang makuha ang estado ng
Z na naka-kondisyon sa pagkuha ng isang partikular na resulta ng sukat a ay simpleng hinahati natin ang probabilidad o sa ibang salita ay
sine-normalize natin ang pangalawang tensor Factor sa pamamagitan ng paghati nito sa sarili nitong Trace kaya sa buod kung gumaganap tayo ng isang
sukat sa X habang ang pares XZ ay nasa estado row ito ang nangyayari una ang bawat resulta a ay lumalabas
na may probabilidad na katumbas ng trace ng PA tensored kasama ang identity oras ng row at pangalawa ay naka-kondisyon sa pagkuha ng
isang partikular na resulta ng sukat a ang estado ng Z ay ibinibigay ng pagpapahayag na ipinapakita sa screen na siyang makuha natin
sa pamamagitan ng pag-normalize ng Matrix na nakita natin kaunti lamang kanina at iyon ay parehong bagay sa paghati ng matrix sa probabilidad
para lumabas ang a dapat kong banggitin na makatuwirang ito lamang kung ang probabilidad ay hindi zero dahil kung hindi ay naghi-divide tayo ng zero
ngunit okay iyon dahil hindi natin kailangang alalahanin ang mga bagay na hindi nangyayari sa bahaging ito ng
aralin ay pag-uusapan natin ang isang simpleng ngunit pundamental na teorema tungkol sa mga sukat na kilala bilang teorema ni Neymar
sa madaling salita ang sinasabi nito ay ang anumang sukat ay maaaring ipatupad tulad ng iminumungkahi ng figure sa screen
ang pagsasalita nito sa mga salita ang isang ibinigay na Pangkalahatang sukat sa isang sistema X ay maaaring ipatupad sa sumusunod na paraan
una ay nagpapakilala tayo ng isang na-initialize na workspace system y na ang mga classical state ay ang mga posibleng resulta ng sukat na inaakala nating
bilang 0 hanggang n minus isa pagkatapos ay ang isang unitary operation U ay ginagawa sa pares
YX at pagkatapos ay ang isang standard basis measurement ay ginagawa sa y kaya lahat ay karaniwang nakatakda
dito maliban sa pagpipilian ng U at ang sinasabi ng teorema ay posible talagang pumili ng unitary operation na ito
U upang ang mga probabilidad para sa iba't ibang mga resulta ay palaging nagkakasundo sa ibinigay na Pangkalahatang
sukat ngayon tingnan natin kung paano napatunayan ang teorema ni Neymar at hindi ito mahirap kailangan lamang nating gumawa ng isang magandang pagpipilian para sa
unitary operation U at beripikahin na gumagana ito ngunit una ay kailangan natin ng isang pangunahing katotohanan
mula sa Matrix Theory na para sa anumang positive semi-definite Matrix P palagi may isang natatanging positive semi-definite
Matrix Q na kung ang Q s ay katumbas ng P sa pangkalahatan ay maaaring may maraming matrix na nagsi-square upang bigyan tayo ng P ngunit
palagi may isa lamang na positive semi-definite ang notasyon na ginagamit natin upang tukuyin ang Matrix na ito ay ang square root ng
p at iyon din ang tinutukoy natin sa kanya sa mga salita kung nais mong kalkulahin ang square root ng P para sa ilang positive
semi-definite Matrix P sa pamamagitan ng paraan ay maaari mong gawin iyon sa pamamagitan ng unang pagkalkula ng spectral decomposition ng p at pagkatapos
ay palitan ang bawat isa sa mga eigen value ng square root nito at iwanan ang mga eigen vector nang mag-isa ang mga eigen value ay lahat non-
negative kaya makatuwirang ito at medyo madaling makita na ang Matrix na makuha natin ay talagang positive semi-definite
at nagsi-square sa P ang katotohanang ito ay Natatangi ay ibang usapin hindi ito mahirap na
patunayan gamit ang ilang pangunahing katotohanan tungkol sa mga matrix ngunit ito ay medyo tangential sa aralin at kukuha tayo lamang ng bahaging iyon
bilang ibinigay at ngayong mayroon na ang Konsepto na iyon ay medyo madaling tukuyin ang isang
unitary operation U na gumagana ang anumang unitary Matrix na tumutugma sa pattern na ipinapakita sa screen ay talagang
gagana ang unang n column na ipinapalagay ang X ay may n classical State tulad ng dati ay nakuha sa pamamagitan ng pagtatambak ng mga square root ng
mga matrix na naglarawan ng sukat sa ibabaw ng isa't isa at ang natitirang mga column ay maaaring anuman na gusto natin
hindi ito gagawa ng anumang pagkakaiba basta ang buong Matrix ay unitary
at sa pamamagitan ng paraan kung mapapansin mo ang isang pagkakatulad sa koneksyon sa pagitan ng Krauss at Stein spring na mga representasyon ng mga channel iyon ay hindi nagkataon at
sa katunayan ang mayroon tayo dito ay karaniwang isang espesyal na kaso nito kung saan ang ating mga cross matrix ay lahat nagkataong maging positive
semi-definite kaya may dalawang bagay na kailangan nating suriin ang una ay ang pagpipiliang ito ng iyo ay talagang gumagana at ang
pangalawa ay posible na piliin ang mga hindi natukoy na column sa isang paraan na ginagawang unitary ang iyo kaya simulan natin sa una
narito ang estado na sinimulan natin ang ibabang sistema Y ay ini-initialize sa zero State habang ang nangungunang sistema
ay nagsisimula sa estado row at pagkatapos ay gumaganap tayo ng U na ibig sabihin ay kinonjugate natin gamit ng
U maaari nating isulat ang lahat ng ito sa mga termino ng mga block matrix tulad ng ipinapakita sa screen mayroon tayong U sa kaliwa UD dagger sa
kanan at K zero bra zero tensored kasama ang row sa gitna na kumukuha ng anyo na mayroon tayo dito kung saan mayroon tayong Row sa
upper left hand corner at mga zero sa lahat ng dako at kung iniisip mo ang produktong ito nang sandali ay maliwanag na ang
mga hindi natukoy na entry ng iyo ay hindi na mahalaga sa lahat dahil palagi silang pinarami ng mga zero na entry ng
Matrix sa gitna at kung pagtrabahuhin natin ang multiplication ay makuha natin ang
Matrix na ipinapakita ngayon dito na inilalarawan bilang isang block Matrix o alternatibo ay maaari nating ipahayag ito gamit ang direct notation
tulad nito iyon ay talagang mas maginhawang anyo para sa atin kaya tutukan natin ang
pagpapahayag na ito at para sa kaginhawaan ay bigyan natin ng pangalang Sigma ang Matrix na ito na siyang isang density Matrix
ang huling hakbang ay ang standard basis measurement sa y kaya kalkulahin natin ang reduced state sa y at
madali iyon dahil sa pagpapahayag na mayroon tayo ay basta ini-trace out natin ang X na naaayon sa pangalawang tensor
Factor kaya ang probabilidad para sa anumang ibinigay na resulta a na lumabas ay ang diagonal na entry na naaayon sa a maaari nating isulat
iyon tulad nito at katumbas ng trace ng square root ng PA * row * ang square
root ng PA at sa pamamagitan ng cyclic property ng trace ay nakuha natin ang trace ng PA * row
na siyang inaasahan natin kaya ang mga probabilidad para sa iba't ibang mga resulta na lumabas ay tama palagi silang nagkakasundo
sa orihinal na sukat na sinimulan natin ang pangalawang bagay na kailangan nating suriin
ay posible bang punan ang mga hindi natukoy na Column ng U sa isang paraan na ginagawa itong
unitary sumusunod ito mula sa katotohanang ang unang n column na siyang mga column na nabuo ng mga square root ng mga matrix na naglarawan ng
sukat ay orthonormal at maaari itong suriin nang direkta ang mga kaugnay na detalye ay narito
sa screen kaya i-pause ang video at maglaan ng ilang sandali upang pag-isipan iyon kung nais mo ngunit tulad ng iminungkahi ko kanina
ito ay talagang isang espesyal na kaso ng isang bagay na naranasan natin sa nakaraang aralin at iyon ang
patunay sa ngayon sa aralin ay inilagi natin ang ating pokus sa mga destructive measurement ibig sabihin ay walang detalye ng
postmeasurement quantum state ng sistemang sinukat para sa isang non-destructive measurement sa kabilang banda ay mayroon
hindi lamang isang classical na resulta ng sukat kundi pati na rin isang postmeasurement Quantum state ng sistemang sinukat at tulad ng
makikita natin ay mayroong natural na koneksyon sa teorema ni Neymar mayroong talagang iba't ibang paraan upang ibahin ang mga non-destructive
measurement sa mathematical na mga termino ngunit magsisimula tayo sa isang pormulasyon na karaniwang direktang nagmumula sa teorema ni Neymar
isaalang-alang ang isang pangkalahatang sukat ibig sabihin ang isang destructive na inilalarawan ng isang koleksyon ng positive semi-definite
matrix p 0 hanggang PN minus isa na nagkakabuuan sa identity maaari nating gawin ito
sukat sa isang non-destructive measurement sa pamamagitan lamang ng pagsasaalang-alang ng implementasyon ng sukat na ito na tinalakay natin sa konteksto ng teorema ni Neymar
nagpapakilala tayo ng isang bagong sistema y nakikipag-interact ito sa X sa pamamagitan ng isang unitary operation U at pagkatapos ay gumagawa ng isang standard
basis measurement sa y kaya ang sistema X ay nandoon pa rin at maaari nating isaalang-alang ang estado nito
at batay sa pagsusuri na ginawa natin ay maaari nating matukoy na ang postmeasurement state ng X na naka-kondisyon
sa pagkuha ng isang partikular na resulta ng sukat a ay ibinibigay ng isang density Matrix na mukhang
ganito sa mga salita ay kinonjugate natin ng square root ng kaukulang measurement Matrix at pagkatapos ay
sine-normalize ang isa pang paraan upang ibahin ang mga non-destructive measurement na mas pangkalahatan ay sa mga termino ng cross
matrix ng mga channel at ito ang depinisyon ng mga sukat na mahahanap mo sa kilalang textbook ni Neil sa
Trang halimbawa ipagpalagay na ang m0 hanggang m m minus 1 ay mga square matrix na nagsasatisfy
ng equation na ipinapakita sa screen na ibig sabihin ay maaari nating isipin ang tungkol sa mga matrix na ito bilang mga cross matrix na naglarawan ng isang
channel sa katunayan ang mga matrix na ito ay naglarawan ng isang channel ngunit naglarawan din sila ng isang non-destructive measurement
at ang paraan ng paggumagana nito kapag ang isang sistema sa isang ibinigay na Estado row ay sinukat una ang mga probabilidad ng resulta ay
ibinibigay ng equation na ipinapakita sa screen ang bawat resulta ay lumalabas na may probabilidad na katumbas ng trace ng ma *
row * ma dagger at naka-kondisyon sa alcome a na lumalabas ang estado ng sinukat
na sistema ay mukhang ganito ang mga non-destructive measurement ng ganitong uri ay maaaring ipatupad sa isang
katulad na paraan sa kung ano ang mayroon tayo para sa teorema ni Neymar at iiwan ko iyon para sa inyong pag-iisip kung
gusto mo posible pa rin na gawing mas pangkalahatan pa ang konsepto ng isang non-destructive measurement halimbawa
mayroong isang konsepto ng isang tinatawag na Quantum instrument na kung minsan ay medyo kapaki-pakinabang ngunit hindi ko sasagutin iyon sa
video sa huling bahagi ng aralin ay maigsi kong tatalakayin ang dalawang gawain na nauugnay sa mga sukat ang Quantum State discrimination at Quantum State
tomography mayroon talagang maraming masasabi tungkol sa parehong mga Konsepto na ito at talagang kakamot lamang tayo sa
ibabaw kaya simulan natin sa pamamagitan ng paglilinaw kung saan nauukol ang mga terminong ito at kung paano sila naiiba
una ay ang quantum State discrimination ang ideya dito ay ang mayroon tayong isang kilalang koleksyon ng mga quantum
state ng ilang sistema kasama ang mga probabilidad na nauugnay sa mga estado na ito upang maging tiyak ay ipagpalagay natin
na ang row 0 hanggang row M minus 1 ay mga density matrix na kumakatawan sa mga posibleng Quantum state ng isang sistema X at ang p 0
hanggang PN minus isa ay mga probabilidad na nauugnay sa mga estado na ito kaya kung ipinagtitipon natin ang mga probabilidad sa isang solong
Vector ay makuha natin ang isang ability Vector ang isang maikli na paraan ng pagsabi nito sa pamamagitan ng paraan ay ang mayroon tayong isang ensemble ng quantum
State at ngayon ang isang abstract na paraan ng pag-iisip natin tungkol sa Quantum State discrimination bilang isang gawain o bilang isang problema
ay una ay isang numero sa pagitan ng Z at N minus isa ay pinili nang random ayon sa mga probabilidad ang sistema X ay pagkatapos ay
inihanda sa estado na naaayon sa random na napiling numero at ang layunin ay matukoy sa pamamagitan ng
isang sukat ng X kung aling numero ang pinili kaya mayroon tayong isang limitadong bilang ng
mga Alternatibo kasama ang isang prior at ang layunin ay matukoy kung aling alternatibo ang talagang nangyari para sa ilang mga pagpipilian ng mga estado at
mga probabilidad ay maaaring madali ito at para sa iba ay hindi posible ang gawin ito nang walang ilang pagkakataon ng paggawa ng error
at mayroong iba't ibang partikular na mga tanong na maaari nating itanong tulad ng ano ang minimum na probabilidad ng paggawa ng error
at ano ang hitsura ng isang sukat na nagkamit ng minimum na probabilidad ng error na ito ang Quantum State tomography sa kabilang banda
ay naiiba dito ay mayroon tayong isang hindi kilalang Quantum state ng isang sistema kaya
karaniwang wala namang prior o anumang impormasyon tungkol sa mga posibleng alternatibo ngunit sa pagkakataong ito hindi ito isang solong kopya ng estado ang
ginagawang available kundi maraming independyenteng kopya ang ginagawang available na ibig sabihin para sa ilang marahil ay malaking bilang
n mayroon tayong n magkaparehong sistema X1 hanggang xn na bawat isa ay independyenteng inihanda sa estado
row at sa pagkakataong ito ang layunin ay mahanap ang isang approximation ng hindi kilalang Quantum State na ito bilang isang density matrix sa pamamagitan ng pagsukat
ng mga sistema kaya sa buod sa Quantum State discrimination mayroon tayong isang solong kopya ng
estado at sinusubukan nating makilala sa pagitan ng isang limitadong bilang ng mga kilalang Alternatibo at sa Quantum State demography mayroon tayong maraming independyente
na kopya ng isang hindi kilalang Quantum State at ang layunin ay mahanap ang isang paglalarawan ng estado na iyon o kahit isang disenteng approximation ng
ito ang Quantum State discrimination ay kawili-wili dahil inabstract nito ang uri ng sitwasyon na karaniwang lumalabas sa
komputasyon at cryptography halimbawa kung saan ang isang alternatibo mula sa isang limitadong set ng mga posibilidad ay naganap at sinusubukan namin o ng ibang tao
na malaman kung alin ito sa pamamagitan ng pagsukat ng isang Quantum system ang pinakasimpleng non-trivial na kaso ay
kung saan mayroon lamang dalawang Alternatibo na ibig sabihin ang m ay katumbas ng dalawa kaya ang gawain ay ang makilala sa pagitan ng isang pares
ng mga estado lumalabas na ang kasong ito ay karaniwang isang ganap na malinaw na problema na ipinapalagay na ang layunin ay bawasan
ang pagkakataon ng maling pagsasalita mayroong isang pinakamainam na pagpipilian para sa isang sukat at madalas itong tinatawag na
hellstrom measurement ito ay talagang isang projective measurement at maaari itong ilarawan bilang
mga sumusunod una ay isaalang-alang natin ang weighted difference sa pagitan ng dalawang Alternatibo ibig sabihin ang p 0 * row 0 minus P1 * Row isa
kaya pinarami natin ang probabilidad ng paghugot ng bawat isa sa dalawang estado sa mga estado mismo at kinukuha natin ang
pagkakaiba iyon ay isang hermitian matrix dahil katumbas ito ng sarili nitong conjugate transpose kaya mayroon itong spectral
decomposition at alam natin sa partikular na ang mga eigen value ay lahat ng tunay na numero kaya ipagpalagay natin na mayroon tayong isang
spectral decomposition na nakasulat sa anyo na ipinapakita sa screen ang susunod na gagawin natin ay ang kolektahin ang
mga eigen value sa dalawang set kung saan lahat ng positibong eigen value ay nasa isang set at lahat ng negatibong eigen value ay nasa
isa pa upang maging tiyak ay kunin natin ang s0 bilang set ng lahat ng index k kung saan ang kaukulang eigen value Lambda K ay
non-negative at hayaan ang S1 na maging natitirang mga index na siyang mga naaayon sa mga negatibong eigen
value hindi talaga mahalaga kung aling set ang naglalaman ng mga index na naaayon sa anumang zero eigen value dito ay gumagawa tayo ng
arbitrary na pagpipilian upang isama ang minus zero ngunit hindi ito gagawa ng anumang pagkakaiba kung ang ilan o lahat sa kanila ay kasama sa S1 sa halip ang mahalaga lamang talaga ay
ang paghihiwalay natin ng mga positibo at negatibong eigen value at sa wakas ay tinu-define natin ang dalawang projection Pi
0 at Pi 1 tulad ng ipinapakita sa screen sa mga salita ang Pi 0 ay ang projection sa
Subspace na sinalihan ng mga eigen vector na naaayon sa mga non-negative na eigen value at ang Pi 1 ay projection sa espasyo
na pinalawak ng mga eigen vector na naaayon sa mga negatibong eigen value ang mga ito ay talagang mga projection at
kung idadagdag natin sila ay makuha natin ang identity Matrix dahil ang mga eigen vector S 0 hanggang S N minus isa ay bumubuo ng isang
orthonormal basis kung ang sukat na ito ay ginagawa sa sitwasyong tinutukoy ibig sabihin ang
estado na sinusukat ay row 0 na may probabilidad na p 0 at ang Row isa na may probabilidad na P1 kung gayon lumalabas na
ang probabilidad ng tamang pagkilala ay may medyo simpleng formula sa mga termino ng mga eigen value Lambda 0 hanggang Lambda n minus
isa hindi ko dadaanin ang mga detalye ng kalkulasyon sa video na ito maaari kang kumonsulta sa nakasulat na nilalaman na naka-link sa video description kung ikaw ay
interesado o tingnan kung makukumbinsi mo ang iyong sarili na ang formula na ito ay talagang tama maaari rin nating ipahayag ang
probabilidad na ito gamit ang isang matrix Norm na karaniwang tinatawag na trace Norm ito ay katulad ng notasyon ng ukian norm para sa mga vector
maliban na mayroon tayong subscript ng isa upang ipahiwatig na ito ang trace Norm ang trace Norm ay napaka-mahalaga at ito ay
napakakaraniwang naranasan sa Quantum Computing ngunit hindi ako masyadong magsasalita pa tungkol dito sa araling ito isang paraan ng
pag-define nito para sa mga hermitian matrix ay ang kabuuan ng mga absolute value ng mga eigen value kaya maaari mong isipin
ang tungkol sa pangalawang pagkakahalaga na ito bilang direktang sumusunod mula sa depinisyong iyon ang trace arm ay maaari ring
tukuyin sa iba pang mga paraan na mas pangkalahatan at mahahanap natin ang tracor muli sa susunod na aralin ito ay talagang
ang pinakamainam na maaari mong gawin ang sukat na ito ay pinakamainam na ipinapalagay na ang iyong layunin ay i-maximize ang pagkakataon ng tamang
hula ang katotohanang iyon ay minsan tinatawag na hellstrom Holo theorem at kung minsan ay tinatawag na lamang na teorema ni hellstrom
kaya hindi mo matatalo ang sukat na ito sa mga termino ng correctness probability at maganda ito dahil
mayroong isang simpleng recipe para sa sukat mismo at isang eksaktong formula para sa correctness probability sa mga termino ng trace
Norm ang trace Norm ay madalas na ginagamit bilang isang paraan ng pagsukat ng observable na pagkakaiba sa pagitan ng mga density matrix para sa
eksakto na dahilan na ito at kapag tumutukoy ang mga tao sa trace distance sa pagitan ng mga estado ay karaniwang tumutukoy sila sa
kalahati ng trace Norm ng pagkakaiba sa pagitan ng dalawang density matrix na dito ay naaayon sa kaso kung saan ang p 0 at P1 ay parehong 1/2 na
isang natural na kaso na isaalang-alang ang Quantum State discrimination para sa dalawang estado ay pinakamainam na naresolba ng
heal from measurement kung saan mayroon tayong isang simpleng recipe at isang simpleng formula para sa correctness
probabilidad kaya ano ang nangyayari kapag gusto nating makilala sa pagitan ng tatlo o higit pang Estado sa kasong ito ay wala tayong
formula sa pangkalahatan para sa pinakamainam na pagpipilian ng isang sukat o isang simpleng pagpapahayag para sa maximum na probabilidad ng
katumpakan gayunpaman ay posible na makahanap ng isang magandang approximation ng isang pinakamainam na sukat sa tulong ng isang computer
at sa partikular ay maaari itong gawin gamit ang isang talagang kahanga-hanga at makapangyarihang optimization technique na kilala bilang semi-definite programming ngunit ito ay hindi
isang bagay na maaari mong feasibly i-implement gamit ang isang lapis at isang piraso ng papel halimbawa sa kabilang banda kung bibigyan ka ng isang tao
ng isang paglalarawan ng isang sukat at sinasabi nila sa iyo na ang sukat na ito ay pinakamainam para sa isang Quantum State discrimination na gawain ay
talagang napakadali ng beripikahin o palsipikahan ang claim na iyon at maaari itong gawin gamit ang tinatawag na Holo Yan
Kennedy LAX conditions hindi ko ipapaliwanag kung ano sila sa video na ito ngunit sila ay mga simpleng kondisyon at medyo malamig
na posible ito narito ang isang halimbawa na nagbabalik sa mga tetrahedral state
na nakita natin kanina sa aralin ipagpalagay na binibigyan tayo ng isa sa apat na estado na ito na pinili nang random na may
probabilidad na isang-ikaapat para sa bawat isa at ang aming layunin ay matukoy kung aling estado ang ibinibigay sa amin hindi ito nakakagulat marahil ngunit
ang pinakamainam na pagpipilian na magagawa mo para sa isang sukat upang gawin ito ay ang tetrahedral measurement hindi ka palaging makakagawa
ng ganito para sa isang arbitrary na koleksyon ng mga pure state ngunit dahil sa mga simetryang kasangkot dito ito ay
gumagana at talagang nakakakuha tayo ng isang valid na sukat at sa pamamagitan ng Holo un Kennedy LAX conditions na binanggit ko
kaunti lamang bago lumalabas na ito ay medyo diretso na patunayan na ito ay talagang isang pinakamainam na pagpipilian ng isang
sukat sa partikular ang nangyayari dito ay ang sukat ay palaging tama na may probabilidad na 1/2 na hindi
masama dahil mayroon apat na Alternatibo kaya ang probabilidad ng tamang hula ay dalawang beses na mas mahusay kaysa sa random na paghula at ito
ay nagkataon na ang pinakamainam na maaari mong gawin para sa mga estado na ito ngayon ay sasabihin ko pa nang kaunti pa tungkol sa Quantum State tomography
kung saan mayroon tayong maraming independyenteng kopya ng isang hindi kilalang Quantum state at ang layunin ay makahanap ng isang approximation ng density Matrix na naglarawan ng
estado na iyon mayroong talagang ilang iba't ibang variant ng problemang ito na nakasalalay sa iyong mga pagpapalagay at sa
partikular sa kung anong uri ng mga sukat ang pinahihintulutan mo halimbawa maaari nating hinihingi na ang bawat sistema ay sinukat nang indibidwal at
ang mga resulta ay pinagsama sa ilang paraan upang makarating sa isang paglalarawan ng density Matrix o maaari nating pahintulutan ang lahat ng
mga sistema na susukat nang magkasama bilang isang solong compound system na mas mahusay sa teorya ngunit ito ay mas
demanding din mula sa teknolohikal na pananaw bilang karagdagan sa mga pagpipilian na ginagawa para sa mga sukat mayroong
din isang mahalagang pagsasaalang-alang na siyang kung paano i-reconstruct ang isang paglalarawan ng density Matrix mula sa anumang data na
makuha mo mula sa mga sukat hindi ako magpupunta sa mga detalye tungkol dito ang aking punto ay ang magmungkahi lamang
na ang Quantum State tomography ay talagang higit pa sa isang umbrella concept na may maraming iba't ibang variant kaysa sa pagiging isang
solong pamamaraan nagkaroon ng napakaraming pananaliksik tungkol sa problemang ito kabilang ang ilang medyo
kamakailang breakthrough na mga resulta na nag-uugnay sa bilang ng mga kopya n sa katumpakan ng approximation na maaaring makuha at patuloy itong isang
kawili-wili at aktibong lugar ng pananaliksik upang tapusin ang aralin ay tingnan natin ang Quantum State tomography
para sa mga cubit at kung paano natin ito magagawa kaya ipagpalagay natin na ang row ay isang density Matrix na kumakatawan sa isang estado ng isang
solong Cubit at ang X1 hanggang xn ay mga cubit na lahat ay independyenteng inihanda sa estado row at para sa
kapakanan ng talakayan na ito ay ipagpalagay natin na ang n ay malaki ang maaari nating gawin ay ang hatiin ang
mga sistema sa tatlong halos pantay na pile at para sa unang pile ay gumaganap tayo ng isang sukat na may kaugnayan sa plus
minus basis para sa bawat resulta na naaayon sa plus ay mag-score tayo ng plus isa at para sa bawat
resulta na naaayon sa minus ay mag-score tayo ng minus isa ang isang mas maikli na paraan upang ilarawan ang sukat na ito
ay ang ito ay isang poly X measurement dahil ang mga plus at minus state ay mga eigen vector ng poly X Matrix at ang
kaukulang mga eigen value ay plus isa at minus isa at sa katunayan iyon ay isang mas karaniwang paraan ng paglalarawan nito at
talagang ang expected value para sa score ay katumbas ng trace ng Sigma x * row ngayon hindi natin kinakailangang malaman kung ano
ang expected value na ito ngunit kung ina-average natin ang mga score na makuha natin sa napakaraming mga Pagsusuri ay malamang na makakakuha tayo ng isang
disenteng approximation ng expected value na ito sa pamamagitan ng batas ng malalaking bilang at mayroong ilang kilalang statistical bound na maaari nating ihagis sa
ito kung nais nating maging mas quantitative tungkol sa pahayag na iyon ginagawa natin ang katulad na bagay sa Sigma y sa pangalawang ikatlo ng
mga sistema ang tanging bagay na nagbabago dito ay ginagamit natin ang mga plus I at minus I na estado na siyang mga eigen vector ng Sigma
Y at katulad nito para sa Sigma Z kung saan ang mga standard basis vector ay mga eigen
vector at pagkatapos sa wakas ay maaari nating gamitin ang formula na ipinapakita sa screen na nagsasabi sa atin kung ano ang dapat na mga coefficient
kung ang row ay nakasulat bilang isang linear combination ng mga poly matrix at sa pamamagitan ng pagpapalit ng ating mga approximation para sa mga coefficient na ito
at marahil ay nag-aayos ng mga ito nang kaunti upang masiguro na makakakuha tayo ng isang positive semi-definite Matrix ay makuha natin ang isang approximation sa
row siyempre mayroong mga detalye na hindi ko pinasok tulad ng katumpakan ng approximation at ang antas ng
kumpiyansa na maaari tayong umasa dito ngunit sana ay nagbibigay iyon sa iyo ng pangunahing ideya ng isang paraan na maaaring isagawa ang tomography sa isang
cubit posible rin na gumawa ng Cubit tomography gamit ang touch o hedral measurement at sa katunayan ito ay lumalabas
na medyo simple at elegante kahit sa mathematical na mga termino ang maaari nating gawin ay ang gaganap lamang
ng isang sukat na ito nag-iisa sa lahat ng independyenteng kopya ng ating hindi kilalang Quantum State at sa pamamagitan ng paggamit ng
kahanga-hangang formula na ipinapakita ngayon dito ay maaari tayong makabuo ng isang approximation ng ating estado sa pamamagitan ng pagtatantya ng trace ng PK *
Row para sa bawat K sa pamamagitan ng fraction ng mga beses na ang kaukulang resulta ng sukat ay lumalabas muli ito ay gumagana lamang dahil sa
perpektong mga simetriya na mayroon tayo sa pagitan ng apat na estado na ito at mayroon talagang ilang kahanga-hangang hindi nalutas na mga problema na nauugnay sa mga generalization
ng diskarteng ito sa mas malalaking sistema at iyon ay isang magandang lugar upang itigil ang aralin salamat sa panonood at
umaasa akong sasali ka sa akin para sa susunod na aralin na tungkol sa mga purification at Fidelity paalam muna